we realized that singapore cuts down a
tremendous amount of trees every day we
started realizing that waste is a big
issue and a lot of the things in
singapore are really not eco-friendly
she gave this to me actually she said
claudia
can you design this
to look like a shawl i don't like it
when people
ask me hey what happened to your hand
i started to rethink how i can construct
them differently
[Music]
when coffee first started a lot of our
event actually got cancelled when that
happened we need to change our strategy
once human activity comes to a
standstill you realize that how clear
the skies are i think the whole world
was
suddenly very conscious about the
environment
i think the difficulty of trying to
tackle mental health and well-being is
that the issue is so invisible
the good design research has really
gives us this opportunity for us to
really see how we can densify the local
wood it's just to make the wood stronger
and more stable
[Music]
what we have over here is the modular
arm sling that prevents it from dropping
out and that's the key difference here
is that it's going to be easier for
everyone you can save time you don't
necessarily have to experience a
disability
the idea of magical moment is really to
create this shared moment between the
kids and the parents and how like we
wanted to have this deep and memorable
connection between them
we can actually recycle timber into mint
fibers so there's no waste it becomes
weatherproof and it's also termite-proof
we could really take a step back and
look at to improve the experience of
someone getting mental well-being and
wellness support what are some of the
things that we haven't tried before
[Music]